[Musique]
un a400m prêt à l'envol cet avion est la
star du transport dans l'armée de l'air
il peut emmener 37 tonnes de matériel
dans ses soutes et volé sur plus de 4000
km l'a400m sera le 14 juillet au dessus
des champs elysées mais il a d'abord
survolé sa propre base celle d'orléans
bricy où le défilé aérien se préparera
désormais chaque année la proximité à la
fois de paris le côté centrale de bricy
a eu les ferveurs de l'état major pour
décider de transférer les répétitions du
14 juillet de châteaudun abri et en
termes d'espacé aérien on est
suffisamment éloignée de paris pour
avoir une liberté d'action liberté d'
espaces on a des espaces réservés pour
les militaires à proximité de bricy ce
qui a justifié la facilité d'organiser
un tel événement l'a400m a donc pu
évoluer dans essentielle or les années
au milieu d'une soixantaine d'aéronefs
locaux ou venus des bases d'orange de
villacoublay et d'evreux tous ont
travaillé leur coordination en vue du
défilé du 14 juillet on a l'habitude
d'évoluer dans des environnements
complexes avec avec énormément d'avions
que ce soit sur les théâtres shamal
barkan donc on a l'habitude d'avoir
beaucoup d'avions
à côté de nous après on a des
convictions qui assure et bien sûr en
termes d'altitude de temps et c'est donc
c'est pas chacun si chacun respecte ses
trajectoires césar de passage tout se
déroule sans accroc
la répétition s'est effectivement
déroulée sans souci majeur il n'ya plus
qu'à réitérer la performance dans quinze
jours au dessus de paris